[Music]
[Applause]
when I first started using Tick Tock it
was just like people dancing or like
joke videos
that's what were most of my videos until
later
I just felt isolated from all my friends
my family
Tick Tock was kind of just there and
then it would just get even lonely and
lonelier
I had no idea that it would make me end
up here
let's talk about tech talk anxiety
depression and eating disorders the
social media giant conceals the dangers
of its app especially to children
to think what these companies are doing
what they know they're doing and the
harms that are being caused in the real
world are horrific horrific
the families of two little girls say
tick tock caused their deaths tick
tock's algorithm keeps young people
scrolling little is known about the
potential mental health impacts it may
happen they have operated under the
belief that they are immune Tick Tock is
repeatedly chosen the path for more
control more surveillance and more
manipulation and they've pulled the wool
over all of our eyes we will keep safety
particularly for teenagers as a top
priority for us
algorithm has one main goal
you need to watch even more videos
if you can control the algorithm then
you can also control the mental health
of a user
and if you cannot control the algorithm
take-toe needs to be shut down
[Music]
thank you
I'm Olivia Carvel I am a reporter on
Bloomberg's investigations team I've
been writing about the intersection of
technology companies and child safety
I've been reporting on Tech talk for
about a year now largely writing about
safety policies that the app has but
what I really wanted to understand was
the actual impact on the users
themselves
so we know that Tech talk has been a
punching bag in Silicon Valley over the
last few years there's a lot of concern
about this app almost every day if you
check Google something new pops up
I'm seeing a lot of headlines around
data privacy around the security risks
of the app
and another thing that comes up time and
time again in these headlines is child
safety concerns
what is the mental health impact of
using an app like tick tock
I want to try and answer that question I
want to understand is Tick Tock safe for
kids and what are some of the
consequences of tumbling into a rabbit
hole on this app
please
what baby
what's going on
all right we need coats for you too here
Bob
you got it all right let's go all the
front door loves
What drew me to this work is that it
needs to be done I'll see you later I'll
be back I'll be right back
[Music]
our children are dying
they're suffering they're developing
harmful dependencies on these products
they're experiencing unprecedented rates
of depression anxiety suicide and these
products need to change
give me a kiss
love you
Laura Marquez Garrett is an attorney
based with the social media victims Law
Center the seattle-based law firm which
is essentially trying to raise the
question of liability should these big
technology companies be held liable for
the harms that they are causing to
children
hello come on in good to see you
so what's been happening lately it has
not been happening lately same same I'm
just busy and a lot of families a lot of
work
we have over 1400 clients right now it's
crazy because the center's only been
around for what 18 months
if even yeah and do you have families
reaching out to you directly to talk I
do you can see this pattern where you
have a kid often a kid that is doing
just fine and you introduce that social
media element and things just go
downhill The Tick Tock cases tend to be
the dependencies that these kids develop
where they just feel they can't live
without it you know you will have a
teenager who's for you Paige is just
flooded with suicide content advocating
violence against others we see that
disordered eating is a big one it will
be massive amounts of video targeted on
a vulnerability that the technology has
identified how do you actually visualize
the landscape of social media harm what
does it look like in your mind it's huge
it's the designs it's the marketing it's
the programming
these products are tools whereby if a
child gets an account these companies
are using these tools to Target these
children I mean we see kids all the time
who will tell us and and you can see it
for the ones that are dead you can see
it in their data from the ones that are
here they will tell us like I wasn't
looking for this stuff
I can't tell you
I can't tell you like the way we feel
when a new client comes through and
their child has passed away recently and
it's not I know we're not responsible
but there's this sense of like we have
to do this we have to get this done
because it's happening every day and I
will tell you that the outcomes where
some of these children survive can be
just as bad these are children whose
childhood is gone
Tick Tock was already pre-downloaded on
my first phone
all my friends had tick tocks accounts
and they were making videos and it was
just some
seemed like something that would be fun
I think my first like recollection of
like the shift in my for you page was
really just like I started getting like
healthy recipes you should start and
then it turned into how to make your
legs thinner and then it turned into
what I eat in a day with these girls
that I thought I should look like
of course it made me feel like I was
eating too much and like what my body
should look like and just that I wasn't
enough because I didn't look like these
other girls or I wasn't doing what they
said I should be doing
I do not remember searching any of that
stuff
at all and then it was there
I found a little icon for the for you
page it made me visibly Shake I stood in
the kitchen for less than 30 seconds and
probably saw 50 images
it was disordered eating
body dysmorphia binging showing pictures
of what it looked like to be anorexic
self-harm it was all over her feed
we thought we were telling her the right
things and we thought we were doing the
right things and unfortunately I did not
know that I was working against the
forces coming through her phone
I need to have your child's 13th
birthday party on a Sunday and Monday to
see your child hospitalized for a
life-threatening disease was
heart-wrenching and for us that was our
Rock Bottom as a family
foreign
we had our first official appointment
with a medical provider and first a
nursing student came in to take her
heart rate
and I saw the pause
and I saw them do the heart rate again
and then I saw the nurse come in and I
saw the same thing
in the afternoon I saw her phone call
come across the doctor said that Katie
needed to be hospitalized and my husband
asked the question of well how soon do
we need to get her there they said you
need to admit her now you need to go
pick her up from school
so we drove to school to pick Katie up
and
um
called the school and Katie was released
and then my husband and I looked at each
other and we thought what if she doesn't
come home
and
what if she dies there and so we called
my son out and we asked my son to come
out too so we could explain it to him
and then Katie got in the car and where
did you think you were going Florida she
thought we were surprising the kids with
the trips of Florida and she looked in
the back and saw that there was only one
suitcase and knew that she was getting
it
[Music]
Katie's a pretty remarkable young woman
she feels a sense of empowerment by
talking about her experience and she
really feels like Tick Tock is to blame
here
she's filing a lawsuit arguing that the
platform is liable for what happened to
her
we're aware of many cases where children
like Katie have tumbled down this eating
disordered rabbit hole and she is not
alone in her experience
[Music]
custom like why they directly sent me
these video
actually of my age and that I was a girl
like
why why me
if Katie had a coach or a teacher that
was encouraging these behaviors they
would be fired we wouldn't allow
somebody to stand in front of children
and give them this information
[Music]
the fact
has an algorithm that was purposeful in
sending harmful content to a child
that's irresponsible
[Music]
foreign
what is powering this product
the concern is no one really knows
this is a document that I'm looking at
it's called Tick Tock algo 101 it was
actually written internally and
effectively tries to explain to the
product guys or the human moderators how
it works
there is a an equation here that they've
outlined trying to explain to these
teams what the algorithm is doing what
it's learning of these users to deliver
you an endless stream of content that it
thinks you want to see
that's tick tock's magic Source here
but through reading this what I've come
to understand is it doesn't really tell
us anything
this has lead to some chaotic
frustrating situations for Insiders
I think one of the most telling things
we actually have in this 18-page
document is a line on the front page
that says our ultimate goal is to
increase daily active users so even if
inside the company their trust and
safety teams which are set up to try and
protect kids are encouraging them to
develop create enhance safety measures
the company's ultimate objective
is actually
working against that
[Music]
I'm Charles I'm 20 years old I'm from
Germany I ended up working for a tick
tock at the age of 18. most of the time
is when I worked at tiktok I did
workshops so I had the chance to really
interact with many advertisers in the
german-speaking region
I saw that my for you feed tremendously
changed in a time of a week or two
every time I enter the workshop I was in
need to switch to a second Tick Tock
account because my personal Tick Tock
account was so dark and sad that I don't
want to really share any of this content
[Music]
what I saw in my feed is more and more
depressional suicide and self-harmful
content came on
this is not somebody saying I want to
kill myself it's maybe somebody sitting
in a dark room crying and a text saying
I don't want to live anymore
you really get affected by that quite
hard
Tick Tock collects a lot of data when it
comes down to the videos that you
consume and all the metrics that you
give to Tick Tock by consuming more and
more content on the platform
the most important factor for the
algorithm clearly is watch time but it
also comes down to a topic called
retention which is based on the
interactions that you give to a certain
video and to a certain Channel
I personally made an experiment where I
opened up a new tick tock account and
tried to check on how much time would it
take for me to open up an account that's
just filled with sad quotes
and it took me 17 minutes to have a pure
negative feed and you really see that
within the first 15 to 20 minutes that
you interact with the algorithm you will
decide what is going to be distributed
to your own feed in the next years on
Tick Tock I had a presentation in
November of 2020 where I had the
opportunity to comment on gen Z Behavior
what's happening on Tick Tock and what
is going on the wrong direction
I put on two videos that were kind of
the worst and most sad content that I
have been seeing on my personal for you
feed just days ago I believe that at the
end for them the takeaway was yeah this
is on our platform okay cool but why
should we do anything we have so much
work to do there was no proactive
engagement in that topic nobody even
replied to my concerns
Tick Tock is aware of content that is
around suicide depression it disorder
and mental health issues and they want
to address that internally but only
under the circumstance that you don't
spend less time on the platform if this
would be taken down
foreign
[Music]
so I'm going to open the tick tock app
on my phone and the first thing I see is
before you feed
this is an endless stream of content
that I can scroll through and watch
videos
the interesting thing about the for you
feed is every single Tick Tock user and
now there's more than a billion around
the world see a different thing on there
for you feed it is hyper personalized to
what the algorithm thinks you want to
see and what it thinks will keep you on
the app for as long as possible
in the early days of social media one of
the concerns about these products was
this concept of filter Bubbles and this
is where we have scenarios of teenagers
and children being pulled into a virtual
reality and being sent content about
certain topics that they don't fully
understand or grasp
I want to understand what that feels
like for
a teenager to be sent never-ending
content about a topic that
has the ability to change their mindset
to change the way they feel
Chase Nazca was a young man living in
New York two-parent households siblings
did well in school incredible athlete
you know he hugs and kisses his mom
goodbye I'm going to the gym Mom rides
his bike to the gym normal routine
nothing out of the usual
[Music]
he works out he leaves the gym and as
he's riding his bike home he stops at an
unfenced area of some train tracks and
he texts his friend and said I'm tired I
can't do this anymore
and he's gone
his parents after the fact trying to
piece things together and figure out
what happened how did this happen are
looking through his cell phone and they
come across the tick tock for you page
and what they see on the tick tock for
you page is horrific
through
I mean over 100 of these videos he had
bookmarked several thousand which is
somewhat unusual a lot of kids don't do
that but as a result it's created a
scenario where we have a lot of what he
was watching up until the day of his
death so you really have his digital
fingerprint right yeah what he was
looking at what he was liking what he
was favoring what he was searching too
so we have and in fact let me pull this
out and I can give you some examples in
January you've got bench press tips
kitchen hacks motivational speech gym
motivation Batman that same day this is
what Tick Tock chooses for him find what
makes you happy I don't want to live
sleeping is not enough I need to die
so this is what tick tock's algorithm is
sending to chase after he searches for a
motivational speech correct
this is a common one that he gets
several times before he takes his life
which is how he took his life
I'm done
oh wow
um here's some violence
kill her kill her now so a lot of what
he starts getting are and it's possible
if we went in we'd find he'd been
through a breakup
um and he starts getting images that are
advocating like one is you're a terrible
person which is why she's not with you
um two is kill her killer I mean a
teenager who's just gone through a
breakup seeing this I mean I have no
idea what kind of impact that's going to
have on you
all right
shall we look at what is on his account
today
I downloaded tick tock on this device
yesterday and then I put in the username
and the passcode and it opened right
into his account
[Music]
with anxiety and nerves and it starts
immediately
you're no good
where are the silly dancing videos where
are the kits and the dog dress up clips
it's just so hard to wrap your head
around
the fact that what we were watching was
specifically sent to a 16 year old boy
who took his own life right this is this
is the rabbit hole this is the wrapping
wall this is Tick Tock I mean we've just
watched a few minutes and it's been
non-stop you should just die you're
worthless you're nothing you're sad no
one loves you you're unlovable these
these companies collect tens of
thousands of data points
I mean you're telling me that that they
know what car you drive what your
education level is what you shop for on
Sunday afternoon but they don't know
that they're causing harm this is insane
this is this is killing American
children
it was a really weird experience
you know I've been reporting for months
now trying to understand what is a
filter bubble what does it feel like to
be inside one and I just saw it
it's hard to find the words to explain
it because
you can talk to families you can talk to
lawyers you can talk to academics you
can talk to researchers but to witness
it and to watch what that 16 year old
boy was seeing before he died what his
account is still being sent now
you know it really feels like you know
these products are failing these kids
[Music]
I want to share with other people that
this is what Tick Tock was sending me
the easier thing would have been to not
say anything but I don't think that's
the right thing the right thing is to
say something so that this doesn't
happen to any other girls and they don't
have to go through what I'm going
through right now
somebody needs to do it and just the
feeling of empowerment it gives me
I want to create the change that needs
to be created
[Music]
there are a lot of issues on Tick Tock
yes do I still like the app and the
content yes it's just about the
mechanism behind it
if you have this content in your feed
you're not alone really make sure that
you spend more time in real life than to
everybody who wants to work in Tech I
think we need to get a little bit less
brainwashed by what the company tells us
and get back to how we personally
experience social media
what scares you the most any sort of
possibility that we can't create change
I don't know what kind of a world we
live in where this continues now that
people are finally starting to realize
what these companies are doing that
scares me the most it's the possibility
that we cannot force these companies to
make these products safer for kids they
know the product's harmful they know
it's hurting kids and they're still
Distributing it to virtually every child
that they can get into their hands
[Music]
thank you